two days after rocking our morning show
world could GMA anchors Amy robach and
TJ Holmes face disciplinary action for
their rumored Affair welcome everyone to
Entertainment Tonight You Know past
videos are going viral people are
invested in this story meanwhile TJ and
Amy were back in their anchor seats
under the watchful eye of I mean
everybody you know it's too bad it's
Friday it's been a great week we just
want this one to keep going
take it all in I am very excited about
the weekend TJ and Amy's playbook for
handling the Scandal avoidance and humor
the co-anchors who are married to other
people did not address the affair rumors
and while there's a report that their
relationship is upsetting GMA colleagues
two sources tell ET that Amy and TJ will
not face disciplinary action because
they are two consenting co-workers who
are equals in a relationship marriage
gets a bad rap a lot of times TJ who
tried out to be an ET anchor shared his
thoughts on marriage during his audition
I'm such a marriage component I want
everybody to get married I think
everybody should and I think you're
better off in doing so that was 2014.
two months later he joined ABC News he
and Amy became co-anchors in 2020 and
we're told they bonded over their love
of running here's my half marathon tip
ask her for tips stop we're never gonna
get through this I thought we were done
and now this Tick Tock video we're the
flirty co-anchors talk training tips is
going viral I run behind you and you
keep the pace you're the Pacer that may
be the PC yeah you're the PC okay so
yeah we're gonna both be finishers and
that's what counts
another tip is to train with friends uh
you set the agenda you stay here I did
and at least you feel the excitement of
doing it with someone you don't feel
alone so when did things get serious
well according to one report both TJ and
Amy separated from their spouses in
August and then the relationship turned
romantic The Daily Mail claims their
friendship evolved into something more
in June when they were both in London
covering the Queen's Platinum Jubilee we
are going to be in full swing here in
London Amy is married to Melrose play
Star Andrew Shu and a source tells E.T
no one would be surprised if a divorce
is in the works when TJ was on our set
he was busy with baby number three and a
loving life with his wife attorney
Marilee fee big my passion these days is
doing baby Babble walking and and
tearing up the house 19 months old we
have a baby girl Sabine is her name my
wife and I've been married about four
and a half years this is our first
hopefully our only one bundle of joy is
enough right now